hi everyone welcome back to LED life
today we are gonna be talking about
advertisement does it really affect you
find out on this episode of LED live
[Music]
well I kind of like everyone thank you
for tuning in and before we dive in into
our topic I want to thank our patreon
support without your support we won't be
here today and for you that having
joined our patreon family join us and
also DOS and in patreon can get another
perks such as the Poe show before we
dive into our topic I'm gonna give you
some ad here we have t-shirt if you go
to our store this spring coms last light
where you can get our t-shirt and your
purchase really help our ministry she
designs a lot of those t-shirts cool
designs and remember advertising works
and this one brought to you by this
documentary called side ology if you
guys haven't watch it you can get it
digitally or DVDs in our stores so
before we begin I'm gonna show you this
clip
[Music]
what do you guys think about that
makes me want to make our intro look
like that that was some clever
camerawork
narrative question what do you guys feel
about this and what do you think they
trying to mark it you know probably be
honest I was kind of distracted by the
message cuz I was just looking at how
cool it was shot but someone thinking
different stuff right but I think I
think that's kind of the message is that
you you actually have a different
vantage point so what they're showing
you when it actually shows you what it's
really made out of is it really all what
it is all right so it's like depending
on how you're viewing that or what
through what lens you're looking at that
changes because if you move to a
different vantage point you can see that
those elements are not the same yeah
it's very like inspirational cuz it has
all the aspects a good message as the
wow factor has a music yeah the music
you see like you know whoa yes cinematic
cool yeah what what a do you think it is
like yeah they look very clean they're
selling toilet papers that's that's much
needed right yeah yeah this is like an
apple an apple
I was wondering because they're big on
to think different like how this company
trying to get us to make feel positive
thing make us feel good about their
product and they actually have this
description in the ad it says here's to
hope to those who have always seen
things differently and then with the
link to their website yeah you know it's
interesting that the words choices that
came up to describe this I mean I didn't
know I have not seen this ad before I
thought it was a different ad when you
first started but it was like I
immediately went that's so creative but
that's how Apple brands themself is like
look at the creativity you can make with
this machine right and it's also like
very futuristic looking and very clean
yeah it's all branded right and just a
little fact like iPhone actually rises
to 72 point 9
million units sold in the fourth quarter
mm and you think each phone is like 59
bucks it's interesting it's comparing to
Samsung which only you know 70 million
and what I read that you know Samsung is
cheaper and they have more features some
some of Samsung has more features and we
wonder why iPhone still yeah so let's
see and I think they've also attached it
to something more than just in use right
I was just like a look but if you want
to look sickness and classy you gotta
have this clean white phone right right
I think it's lifestyle they show how it
integrates into your whole life like oh
yeah I need that for my life right so
the first app actually started with just
a pen second dad it's just this watch
it's called bulova watches in 1941 and
do you know how much they paid for the
ad in 10 cents 150 bucks
no they paid only $4 to $9 in 1941
now you said is it's like a motion that
is it a video yeah like something that
was on TV yeah the TV was was getting
its yeah well but the TV was really
getting a steam in the fifties and
sixties oh yeah and then in the 1960s
it's all changed because of the Super
Bowl Super Bowl came and guess how much
the cost has like tens of thousands it's
yeah it's thirty seven five hundred
thousand yeah and then you have a same
company doing ad over and over and over
throughout the night and that was in
1960s and that was probably a lot of
money to them back then right and you
know today the Super Bowl ad is 5.6
million thirty-seconds 5.6 million
dollar
yeah it's like hundred and Wow
I don't know yeah I don't know if this
is the new figure the old but it's
something like a hundred and eighty-six
thousand dollars a second or something
like that ridiculous I mean more money
than you make in a year it all centers
around emotion though I mean that's why
an ad during the Superbowl is more you
know expensive than an ad at any other
time even though you can have something
else where people are like watching as
many people are watching like the
Superbowl it's still it's like they know
that if they play the ad when people are
in this heightened state of emotion that
it's easier to sell a product right says
that you know when you're watching a
show they get you to this heightened
state of whatever and it's like boom
commercial breaking like ah yeah but now
you're at that state when you're seeing
all these commercials yeah all purposely
done so let's see the first car
commercial here nice horse-and-buggy
arrows on me one thousand dollar car
then the speed is only twenty miles no
maximum speak mmm interesting the car
was it it's called the Winton mod poor
carriage well it's like a horse carriage
or is it actually a car I actually a
motor carrier did you know that the
wheel width of a car is actually the
same wheel width as a horse-and-buggy
and the reason they did that is because
when think about when roads first were
designed they didn't have cars where
that can drive all over they had horses
and buggies so the cars had to go on the
same road which they had to place the
wheels in the same distance apart to
actually do that yeah kind of
interesting that's interesting and if we
pay attention to this ad you can see
that they only described the the fact
and features of the car you know it's
the best vehicle of its kind it is
handsome really strongly and yet lightly
constructed elegantly finished you know
all these facts right and let's see
what's happened today
Saints nothing right and if you think of
most car commercials today they show you
the lifestyle of the
they're usually traveling to the
nightclub or there you know if it's like
a Kia or something you know it's like
all the friends going to a rave you know
that's like it's like really it has
nothing to do with the car I remember
when I think it was Kia or it was like
one of those little cube cars or
whatever and they played some sort of
like Club II type of music and and it
just blew the band out of the water like
the band just all said and got famous
and they sold out of the car and it was
just because of the way that they
portrayed these kids going to a rave it
was it was really interesting yeah that
made me think of the commercial with the
hamster yeah this guy just say now is
the best time to buy a fall for before
propos costs on luxury car increased
interesting on the your luxury sedans
you know they they usually play like the
classical music and sophisticated yeah
every find the person make people feel
classy or even on like a van my minivan
was full of kids and a family just like
action movie like action film music
going crazy
I remember you showing a clip of Jaguars
you remember that commercial car
commercial was like all like they were
asking the question why is it that in
Hollywood movies the it's always played
by the Brits the villains Yeah right and
then it was like they were always rich
and sophisticated and they were like we
Drive Jaguars that's why this was so
interesting it was a whole campaign they
did several ads they built a website the
whole thing and their their whole slogan
for the whole campaign was it's good to
be bad and it was all very James
bond-esque you know really exciting you
see the wealthy and that type of
personality rather than like you know
this car will drive this X distance and
not how long it'll last
okay so yeah today because there is a
lot of car brand out there so they're
they're shifting their focus instead of
telling you what they're selling they're
telling you why they are selling it and
why you should have it
this other one coca-cola they are famous
with
they're saying half a coke with a smile
no they didn't say you defined for this
long you know that yeah it's it's
interesting you look at modern as they
don't tell you anything about the
function of the product right it's like
the lifestyle all right
yeah which now without like okay yeah
yeah fascinating you think about
cigarettes you know they come with a
warning on them yeah what if every
product you bought came with a warning
of long-term implications right cause
obesity yeah but it doesn't affect me
right yeah I think the most powerful
argument for the the media because this
is something that that our ministry
discusses a lot and if you kind of
discuss well how am I really affected by
what movie I'm watching like you know
I'm a Christian I go to church I read my
Bible so I know the truth there's
probably not a movie that's gonna tell
me to you know
renounce my god and and and isn't that
but the proof is actually you know in
the pudding that they can prove
monetarily how much you're affected by
they spend millions of dollars trying to
affect people they wouldn't spend the
money if it didn't work right
alright yeah the next question then if
it doesn't affect us why they spend
money on ads right I'm pretty sure it's
not just to market their product they're
maybe trying to say my some message the
culture and society tax deductions
there's a really interesting documentary
in fact I think you guys should watch it
if you haven't watched it it's called
art and copy you heard of this
documentary you've heard of it
so they took all the major slogans like
Nike just do it do you know where Nike
just do it came from no I
it was just reading about this it's
actually pretty crazy they they what's
his name Phil Knight he hired a graphic
designer
to come up with that and this great I
mean they paid
he paid him some like or she like nine
dollars or something or on Thursday it's
forty five dollars nine dollars
something like that and they whipped out
that you know Nike swoosh so this slogan
just do it whoever was it part of that
company was watching something on I
think it was either TV or something
where they had a firing squad and the
guy that was gonna get shot he literally
goes just do it like this and the guy
was like I'm gonna call the company that
or whatever like that and that's how the
slogan got attached what a night this
was a real event it's a really bad like
someone was really getting shot and and
the guy was just like just do it you
know like I do it already and then
that's that was inspiration comes in
strange business yeah right but this
ardent copy was pretty fascinating cuz
it went through all the ones like got
milk you know all that where's the beef
you know we do you hear a nice slogan
okay I also like government ads those
aren't even a brand well you think about
how we're those you're watching TV and
all of a sudden the government says beef
this was for dinner like Milken I even
produce now you're promoting that your
company it's just the government telling
this is what you need right and and so
you know these things have influence
culture and that's what was getting at
the the kind of art and coffee
documentary was getting at was really
like all of these things has actually
influence and that Nike just do it
inspired a whole generation to just get
out there and exercise I mean it
actually had a had a profound effect on
the population yeah so the next one I'm
actually gonna show you that just do it
Oh baby Daniel is just waking up
he's gonna win a state championship one
day this guy he'll run a marathon
well you man she is gonna have the best
swing in the state that's right
she will totally win the city open turn
oh my god you get out all of these
athletes are terrible now but they'll
all do big things one day but this is
where everyone reaches their athletic
peak go Barry
cool very cool
one year ago I said she would score
every time she had the ball and guess
what when everyone pushes their limits
they reach their maximum potential and
they live happily ever after and your
mother's gonna kill me so sorry ma'am
what are you doing I didn't mean jump
off a friggin cliff he chickened out
sprint the spinner you can't either
Zach what are you doing on top of that
van Aaron where you guys doing
watch this
I can't take it
this is our whoa
that is humiliating on so many levels
giancarlo Sorento what kind of training
is that excuse me sir Sir Nigel that is
so unnecessary you can't be the star of
every sports yes you can come on let's
do this no no let's not do this run
everybody is going way too why is no one
listening to me
you too ma stop the race is over ma'am
okay no no no no no kid please please
don't do this
[Music]
this is out of control
that's brilliant and you know actually
when they after they make that back line
just do it their sale increase to eight
hundred million dollars Wow I mean
undecayed it becomes 2 million done I
mean when you watch an ad like that just
with the music and you see all these
amazing things it just makes me want to
like go out and like do something
alright it really doesn't have to change
trade my Adina's out see this one is the
Apple first ever commercial ever 1994 84
mmm yeah their first commercial they
don't even say in this commercial you
know what they're selling or the the
features of their product
[Music]
secure from the pests
we are
[Music]
On January 24th Apple computer will
introduce Macintosh and you'll see why
1984 won't be like 1984 wow so the
company was originally called madhouse
but I thought it was I thought it was
Macintosh and then it went to Apple oh
okay okay okay so yeah in this
commercial they actually trying to
inspired people that they can be free
from the Big Brother presumably IBM and
right now oh they actually paid like
more than $600,000 for this app to be
aired in the Super Bowl Wow so that's
not even counting production cost huh
all right this is just paying well but
right now they are worth more than one
trillion dollars yeah spend money to
make money you know I just found the
news that Jobs his wife that was left
with all that money I think it was
equivalent to twenty four billion
dollars that she has made it her life
mission that she will not pass that
money to her kids
it is her sole job to give away all that
money and then she said Steve Jobs
actually wanted it that way
and she was like I'm not interested in
building financial legacies for my
children they got to start over
wow that was kind of cool yeah that's
interesting
yeah can you imagine if your kid mom
please twenty-four billion dollars they
said one yeah say you could still work a
day of college or something yeah they
gave me that money you can make
investments in things I'm sure they're
gonna do that but she's got her fingers
and tons of foundations and hopefully
maybe some nations support little light
we use Apple missus jobs right
so the first why advertise they're
willing to pay a lot of money because
you can use advertisement as a meaning
to empowering and accepting accepting
groups there are less relatable or less
acceptable mm-hmm
for example in the first Cheerios ad
sometimes ago I forget exactly when they
made this ad with interracial couples in
their ad that is pretty simple they
didn't say anything racial or something
but they many people you know they
didn't agree with that ad and they
commented on Sirius YouTube page like
some racist comment like Sirius had to
disabled comment because of that Wow
I mean it reminds me of like when bolts
the runner remember they were saying
like he's from Jamaica and you know
Jamaica it's like the whole
homosexuality thing is like sort of
frowned upon in that country and so they
they put him in a commercial in a dress
and it was to break down the cultural
and you know understand and
interestingly even though they receive
some backlash they brand exposure went
up 77% controversies yeah yeah even if
it's negative like they still pass it
around I think some people purposely
tried to be racy in that you know and
push the cultural norm also a 9su dolla
G right that guy he was like he made
that movie and he put these like real
controversial billboards up and then he
would go and like spray paint on like
there's something up against the movie
and it made the news and everything like
wow this is so controversial that he was
playing about yeah it's like and it made
his movie just blow up cuz people are
like no I'm gonna go see this movie you
know that's so controversial alright and
here
yes honey dad told me that Cheerios is
good for heart is that you says here
that Cheerios has whole grain oats that
can help remove some cholesterol and
that's heart healthy it's really simple
there's nothing racist about it right it
was just at that time it was not in the
norm just kind of edgy controversial all
right but since then you know more
company put interracial family in there
at so what you're saying is if they put
something out on television or in the
media and you see it over and over and
over and over again it's gonna become
normal to people all right that's
fascinating I'll just leave it at that
okay and then the second why is
advertisement can give a voice to those
outside the mainstream and the LGBT
people yeah so we won't also over 20
years ago
IKEA ran their first commercial that
featured a gay couple over 20 years ago
mm-hmm over 20 years ago but they
received many backlash even a bomb
threat whoa
that's how mom and the you guys people
are just crazy aren't they like I'm
gonna come blow up your store because
you had this in the show I mean that's
like you just blast you my god on
Lucifer I'm gonna go bomb you know like
I mean seriously if you if you
negatively slammed a law in a commercial
oh yeah I guarantee you that company
would would would probably have to shut
its doors for a little while you know so
yeah and you know other companies Saudis
IKEA what happened to them so instead of
stopping making commercials that are
getting gay people they make it
more subliminal they make it more subtle
like company like Subaru they have their
tagline you know get out stay out or the
other one entirely comfortable with its
orientation oh oh that's interesting
you gotta wonder if you know these
things work together it's not just about
making way for the company it's like for
its different ways of making money for
the company
so let's find what controversy we can
stir it up or if people actually
approach a company and say hey we need
your help with this can we partner up so
you get sales on your item and we
actually get our message out as well
yeah companies are interesting they they
have to be on everybody's side exactly
right because that's the customer so no
matter what the issue is they're always
trying to move and shift and and all of
that to be on everybody's side was just
like there was a few years ago they're
on the Super Bowl there was a couple of
commercials one was for Budweiser and
their commercial was about immigration
and it took the story of the guy who
founded Budweiser and showed how he was
coming from Germany to America and all
is about having a hard time and this was
just like two to three weeks after Trump
was elected and passed the Muslim ban
all right and here they had that
commercial in the Super Bowl they also
aired same same day Airbnb and they went
through a whole bunch of faces weren't
really advertising your product had you
know wasn't about where you're gonna
stay next or anything and just different
people different faces parts of their
faces maybe half three-quarters you know
all of it and talking about how we all
belong you know we're all more similar
than we are different this kind of stuff
and really interesting timing you know
they're essentially saying we don't care
what the president says we're on the
side of our customer yeah I was gonna
say really marketers they're just
worried about getting everybody's dollar
no matter who it is so how'd you beat
eking he said you know hey Apple will
pay you this much if you represent us
well that's just money to us I mean I
just showed Keith an Apple commercial
yesterday
of like a whole pride parade that they
gave everybody in the in the parade
a white Apple shirt and I don't know
what this tag line was hashtag proud I
think is what it was and it was like
Apple was putting its stamp on on the
whole LGBT and say proud of it and it
was just the Big Apple logo in there
like a Pride Month where all these
companies switch out there right the
logo for the flag they just created a
whole bunch of free advertisement with
that shirt and hallmark you know there's
a situation with the commercial you
really think it was about the company's
morality no they took the commercial
down because 1 Million Moms boycotted
them and they have a lot of influence
and that's okay we'll take this down but
an LGBT company came and they were like
oh what are you doing so then it's like
to make the apology and it's like yeah
trying to please everyone but then but
then did it please everyone you know
because you either leave it up or take
it down and one groups upset one groups
happy so who are you pleasing yeah I
think once again it still puts there
your name on people's lips you know and
it's like no matter how you cut that
cake its promotion yeah a my Daniel 20
years ago they got into trouble and
today we see it everywhere well you know
what IKEA because we thought it was time
for a serious dining room table and we
were slightly different taste I mean
Steve's more it's a country it frightens
me but at the same thing I had
compassion we've been together about
three years I met Steve my sister's way
I was really impressed with how just
well-designed the IKEA furniture was
really into craftsmanship in these
chairs they're really sturdy this table
concluded a leaf leaf means come and
staying together commitments we've got
another leaf waiting when we really
start getting along what are you guys
doing about that yeah I think in you
know the fact that they're they're you
know putting that out there as as this
is normal is it it's gonna influence
people to you know ultimately think you
know yeah this is normal and oh this is
the sbarro act look
and stay out Pearsall I mean love
conquers all is like their tagline right
having to do with cars or is it right
and and and you wonder like you know how
we're all we don't like to support
things that we share that same common
belief so you know maybe perhaps if
you're not in the LGBTQ community you
might read this ad and be like oh cool
love conquers all in that you'll leave
it at that but then there might be
someone who's a part of that whole
lifestyle and is like ah dude I'm gonna
drive a Subaru now you know they're
supporting my people hmm I mean even
like say 50 years ago if you saw a
rainbow and it said love conquers all
you're like you know this is like a
beautiful Christian message
you know like God's promised that he
won't ever destroy the earth with a
flood that's love you know think again
right we just totally rebranded it all
right
yeah listen really has to do with car
yeah and they actually don't have to be
subliminal anymore look at this movie
onward no longer do they have to be
implicit with it or like its implicit
the right words like hidden they don't
have to hide it anymore ambiguous yeah
or have the couple in the background or
are you not really sure whether they're
a couple or not maybe they could be
friends or sisters know this person this
female just comes up and says yeah my
partner this my wife that and they just
keep it pushing as if it's just regular
conversation yeah so every year ya know
it becomes normal yeah yeah and so the
third thing is that advertising can
actually shape culture you guys believe
that absolutely and that's that's where
like seriously watching that documentary
art and coffee really kind of gives you
because it's actually the advertisers
that came up with these slogans and
worked on these productions and they're
the ones telling you you know like yeah
it had this effect into the population
so you know I think you'd have to really
do some mental gymnastics to say it
doesn't affect you and if it didn't
cultures whole regions wouldn't be
asking for bans on certain movies or
alterations being made onward that scene
the lesbian eyford we have a link to the
article on our Facebook page go check
that out oh yeah they banned that whole
scene because of the fact that the
character was out and then you have was
a venom that's banned in my China and
things like that so yeah if it did if it
didn't affect culture these people will
be taking these measures it's a good
point yeah I'm sitting there thinking
about movies that have like alternate
endings and stuff what was that one I
was a well years ago that had a
different ending for Japan in the u.s.
yeah Pearl Harbor Wow yeah really that's
right they didn't want they didn't want
him to like appears like they were
heartless and this and that and and
China actually has invested a lot in
American media and asked for you you
need to put you know Chinese actors in
there and you can't say anything bad
about China because they know just
having Chinese people in there and the
representation is gonna ultimately
influence our population to to see in
the positive light we want to put an
anime plug-in there if you just Google
like China's influence in Hollywood
they're actually behind a lot of the
dollars being poured into the
production's
and so when you when you're the
executive producer meaning you've paid
for this production you can have a lot
of sway of like you got to do this and
this and this otherwise I take my money
yeah so we have this idea that it
because our demand this company makes
more but it's actually not the company
make us have those demand by
manipulating our feeling what do we want
creating this false meet in ourself like
we can see that some modern ads tell us
that we are you know we're not
attractive now we are not smart enough
we're not cool enough but if you use our
product your problem will be solved or
even your oppressed and this is how you
should liberate yourself right yeah
I keep thinking Sood ology man this is a
perfect show for that documentary
definitely got to check it out but help
me remember how it went but
I remember there was some guy who made a
quote saying we had to basically totally
reprogram people's minds about buying
things because it used to be
I need this I'm gonna eat it today or
whatever and you buy it but now there's
now it's like you go in there and it's
like don't need it can't afford it and
you walk out with it or whatever the
Amero I'm talking about
yeah the do business the Business
Insider Adam Fraser yeah he was
basically saying that you appeal to
people's emotions and when you're
actually appealing to their emotions
then people will make an impulse and and
do things that they normally wouldn't do
and so that's it's all honed in and it's
specifically targeting your emotions
like you said making a hole in you that
you're deficient and then they have this
solution for your deficiency and seems
to be like two specific ones either
humor or like heart wrenching well the
reason why they use humor do you know
like like beer commercials and things
why are they so funny
I mean seriously some of them are
hilarious right because everybody likes
to laugh laughter feels good to us and
so they if they release those feel-good
chemicals in your brain and then quickly
associate their program product with you
when you're laughing and then you see
their brand you go I like that when
we're happy yeah it makes me think of
every time I see a comedians face I
always yeah
you see Robin Williams you think funny
he's not always funny all the time that
was part of what made him depressed so
think about like you had to be his
jester you know and just make everybody
laugh all the time when he was just a
normal person but I and you can't take
people seriously like when Jim Carrey
would played 23 or whatever it was like
some people couldn't take them serious
because you're associating him with that
laughter all the time mm-hm
advertisement can also impact values our
values like normalizing what is not
actually good in our life like the LGBT
movement or you know being drunk like no
sphere commercial or smoke cigarette
like cigarette commercial and I don't
know if you remember in the old time in
the 40s
I think 50s when the doctors they
promote cigarette yeah we're doctors
smoke camels you have a problem
breathing here smoke this
yes all right
yeah just see when you have that time
people think by smoking you will feel
better you're killing those germs that
are in fact in there I remember when the
cigarette companies actually had to take
away their cartoon images because that
was appealing to kids like they
psychologically knew if they saw a camel
that that they would be drawn to that
camel and the US government forced them
to you cannot have a camel as your as
your logo anymore I saw that thing as a
kid girl I thought it was cool people
thought that smoking drinking it's so
cool or being LGBT so cool right and
everybody people they want to be
different like we see in the first Apple
commercial you know think differently
right but they're actually doing the
same thing yeah they just make you think
you're doing different things it's it's
amazing because like with the doctors
you know it's like everything is
operating on this logical fallacy right
if the doctor smokes a camel well then
how could it be bad for you all right
it's like the celebrity endorsement yeah
you know if you were the beats
headphones like LeBron then you're gonna
be like LeBron yeah he's got all the
money in the world you'll be able to
jump that high and dunk like LeBron it's
also they attach a sense of loyalty yeah
yeah you got to prove yourself are you
oh you gotta do this yeah you can't do
that you can't buy this or associate
with this if you're attached to
something else
wow I was guilty of that I remember I
used to like Taylor Swift and they have
this promotion with this ice cream you
know if you buy this ice cream you're
gonna get this code and you can get the
submerged so I actually made it that's
why I originally started like an adidas
goes my favorite band at the time of
corn work and this was something that I
didn't fall for it
so yeah and here's a comedian it was
like yeah like you guys saw me drink
coca-cola
I drank Opel and promoted that but then
Pepsi came along and I drank for that
guess what they will taste the same I
support both because they're paying me
like I've nothing to do about what I
like yeah yeah have you ever seen like
like these American Idol type shows or X
Factor's or whatever they all have like
their Cup on the table right their cup
on the table in a sexy endorsement by
like Snapple or coca-cola or whatever we
got a lot of branding on this on this
table here you know there's light bulbs
everywhere just so you know this show is
brought to you by a little white studio
yes don't forget to subscribe that's
right
[Music]
try this Wow meet your new best natural
whiter skin it's truly a beautiful new
new black and white to start something
beautiful okay for whiter skin this is
how the culture in Asia is getting
influenced like oh wow porcelain dollars
yeah that's how beauteous in Asia it's
funny how like it goes to different
trends because you know there's like tan
was in for a while and everybody just
wanted to be like damn darker the better
you know yeah and I like but in 1800
yeah it was like being like pale skinned
was like a sign of you didn't work very
much and yeah it's funny how it's kind
of like swings back and forth it's it's
amazing how the devil is always working
to create dissatisfaction right in all
parts of your life so in Asia you know
it's like if you're trying to get white
skin over here in America they're
looking at everybody that's you know tan
and jealous the status of you going on
vacation if you have curly hair you want
straight hair if you have straight hair
you want curly hair it's like nobody's
ever satisfied with what they have
another example how this advertisement
company really you know trying to shape
certain culture in different country and
also Association like they have the
product next to a fresh purple yes so
your associate yeah you're associating
your own fresh and natural a little do
they know of course you know but it's a
bunch of chemicals you know and nothing
fresh that's what I'm saying I read it
avocado it's probably gonna be like some
citrus or made with avocado but it's
like the last thing on the ingredient
list is less than a percentage
everything yeah I'm always amazed by
marketing terms like made with real
fruit ingredients I was just
as opposed to artificial ingredients I
try to get the all natural turn around
how can you all right that's right
they're putting other positive things
around it so it looks like fresh and
real and so and let's get to the
children and advertisement for the Paris
this is important because average young
person growing up in the United States
are exposed to anywhere between thirteen
thousand to thirty thousand advertised
on television each year Wow they say
babies can recognize brands oh that's
interesting some golden arches I want
french fries yeah yeah oh and this is
interesting because why they targeting
children because they think that by
targeting them since they were a kid it
will give them royalty until they're
adult and also it can influence the
adult because if the kids you know they
want french fries they will ask the
mother and the father they won't ask
each other if we want french fries right
mm-hmm
and also if we see in proverbs 22:6
train up a child in the way he should go
and when he is old he will not depart
from it just go Satan's counterfeit for
everything he's like wait Trandoshan I
got rid of a child he understands human
nature and this is an interesting clip
about how advertisement affecting
children so let's see here's why we need
Wii U anyone can be like a superhero
Billy rabbit Trix are for kids hi I'm
Brett kids spend a lot of time on
screens these days and where there are
screens there are ads and lots of them
in this video you're gonna learn how
advertising rewires kids brains Carl
Sagan once said that the visions we
offer our children shape of the future
but these days we're not treating kids
like shapers of the future we're
treating them like shoppers of the
future how by serving up ads everywhere
on TV with product placements and the
shows they watch in apps and even in
video games but kids don't always
understand that advertising isn't
designed to shape them into healthy
happy adults it's designed to sell them
more stuff some marketers even
intentionally take advantage of young
people's insecurities and their desire
to fit in
we're going shopping and that's all
because advertisers care about what's
best for their bottom line
now what's best for kids so what do
children learn from this constant stream
of advertising kids learn that buying
more stuff leads to more happiness in
short the more ads kids see the more
materialistic they become that means
that they're more likely to say they
want to be rich and famous when they
grow up and then having lots of money is
important to learn more I talked to this
guy Josh from campaign for a
commercial-free childhood explain some
of the consequences of these
materialistic values research shows that
kids who are more materialistic report
lower levels of happiness and that's not
surprising giving that materialism
teaches us that stuff is what's
important in fact it's actually our
relationships and our life satisfaction
that makes us happy these materialistic
kids also have lower academic
performance and it may be because
they're more concerned with appearing
successful than actually learning new
skills and ideas and when it comes to
sharing and caring
well they don't care about that either
when asked what they would do with the
money if they won the lottery kids who
were more materialistic are less likely
to say they would use that money to help
oh yeah they're less likely to care
about the environment too
the research shows that materialistic
kids are less likely to recycle or turn
off the lights when they leave but
advertising doesn't just affect kids
brains it's harming their bodies too
about 98% of televised food ads that
kids see are for unhealthy foods like
soda candy and fast food studies have
shown the more ads for unhealthy food
that kids see the more of this unhealthy
food that they eat raising their risk
for obesity diabetes and other health
complications black and Hispanic kids
and teens are exposed to twice as much
junk food marketing as their white peers
so yeah advertising is really bad for
children and for society at large but
here's the good news
people know that advertising to children
is a problem in one poll in 2014
57% of respondents supported banning all
advertising to children you can be part
of the solution too let's help kids
understand what commercials and
marketing are all about and teach them
that more stuff doesn't bring more
happiness just as kids learn negative
lessons from advertising they can
unlearn it too and that starts by asking
questions if you watch media with your
children that gives you the opportunity
to have conversations when the
advertisements come on
you can ask your children what does the
ad trying to do who made it but it's
also important to reduce children's
screen time not only will that improve
their academic performance help with
their relationships and make them more
physically healthy but it will also
reduce their exposure to advertising
which is trying to convince them of the
big lie that's stuck that will make them
happen
groups like the campaign for a
commercial-free childhood can help so
the campaign for commercial-free
childhood has all sorts of resources to
help parents and caregivers reduce the
amount of time that children spend with
ad-supported screens and finally we
advocate for policies that will protect
children for marketing because if we
don't want less materialistic kids it's
important
change the rules of society so that all
kids have a chance to grow up and be
citizens first and consumers later
thanks for watching did we miss anything
let us know in the comments below and if
you like this video be sure to LIKE and
subscribe in the situation in the
supermarket where a kid wants something
and their parents keep saying no no no
not really explaining why I just saying
no so it's like building this thing up
on the kid like man as soon as I get
some money as soon as I'm on my own I'm
gonna buy all of this stuff you know
what's interesting to me is as we've
analyzed movies and its impact upon your
like actual life but then here's
something that where they're not even
discussing like any sort of movies
they're literally like the more ads
you're exposed to you're gonna have this
like profound shift in your life you're
gonna be less caring about other people
more materialistic you're gonna have all
these character traits just from the
advertisements not not even forget the
movies or the TV shows they're watching
just that usually are short yeah like
movie like one hour two hour I just you
know can be five-second second you can
change the whole mentality right mm-hmm
and also before we go to how they
accomplish this purpose let us see us
this four biggest company that dominates
our lives Google Facebook Amazon and
Apple so this is an interesting article
from Scott Galloway a professor of
marketing at the New York University
Stern School of Business
so he said about Google first that as
homo sapiens we are always searching for
answer where we are searching for answer
from from somebody above and say we pray
and we ask question I mean like how is
this gonna be when I grow up or will my
kid will be alright who might attack us
and we threaten Google like that now we
just ask yes my kid will be okay right
so we basically make Google as our God
with a capital G
yeah if we make Google as our immediate
all-knowing Oracle of answers from
trivial to profound questions and the
second one is Facebook
we are also she'll be and Facebook
matures we are okay we are we are
created to be social being and Facebook
make sure to meet the needs of being
loved and to love and do you think it's
exciting when you go to Facebook and
then you see your old friends or
somebody give a like on your pose or you
like somebody's pose more view like an
illusion of love but somehow Facebook
make it feels like you're connected
right and they can hook you in there and
the next one is Amazon Amazon can't yeah
okay so Amazon acts like our craving our
hunger we always crave for more sugar
more sweet more carbs and Amazon make us
Mercedes Amazon make us yeah it's like
that they have everything from A to Z
and so it's like you're gonna get
whatever you need from this company
that's probably their amo yeah they want
us to crave more stuff that we don't
even need a cheap price but if you spend
ten extra dollars you get free shipping
and here you get this cool thing
everybody that bought this also bought
this don't you like it
right right and the last one is Apple so
he said that the second most powerful
instinct after survival is procreation
and as a sexual creature we always want
to signal how elegant smart and creative
we are interesting and alcohol make us
look like that you know if you own an
Apple product people see that we are you
know we make money we we know how to
live we are
elegant and smart that's what Apple does
to us like I like the watches yeah it's
true when I see when I see people who
have all Apple everything even the phone
and I and I just see that it has like
multiple multiple cameras on the back of
their phone then I'm like I know how
much you paid for that
yeah so this comment I get really smart
they're really playing on our needs our
main needs and then they surpass that
into the once and then the once over
take the needs and was just like wow
yeah so let's see more how do they how
do they accomplish this purpose so this
is some psychology of advertising
so basically 31% of advertisement or
emotional contents it's not even
rational it's just emotional right okay
you really don't need that but you want
it like when you see an ad of this car
looks cool make you look famous or make
you look like you're the coolest guy in
town you don't need it but you want it
right and you can't afford it so they
trapped in these small payments over the
span of multiple years of your life all
right
and you're it's usually tearing apart or
you want a new one by the time before
you even finish paying for it mm-hmm
and also they use you know they use
color and they use our empathy they use
our okay
so they use our empathy you know with
the emotional content and they use our
creativity - how - by making the ad oh
by appealing the add to our feeling to
make us feel happy when I when we see
their brand this is some example of the
ad the real beauty campaign the you know
how they use different types of girls
instead of just one girl yeah that's
pretty cool yeah that one is actually
pretty cool
and this one the coca-cola
you know smile with the coke we don't
tell you that the happiness factor ever
seen like an animation commercial with
coca-cola that you know it just just
look like a fun place and so when you
when you watch the commercial you were
just like wow
coca-cola is just fun you know yeah you
know I think we have a good time right
it has a lot of sugar and other stuff
that you don't need yeah and also
Google's the friends forever campaign
says the the video depicts some
surprising animal friendship and has
attracted more than six million shares
across Facebook Twitter because you know
that company's paying attention to what
everybody's watching what everybody's
like searching and they're just going
everybody's searching cute cat videos so
if we put some cute little fuzzy animal
in there which we know everybody likes
and then associate our brand with it I
watch a lot of them I did too good for
the family it's not pushing that agenda
it's like God's nature nature's
comedians so yeah and how this
advertisement actually get to our brain
and there is a there's two routes on how
do they get to our brain the first one
is the central route is the route that
use facts and logic is just straight to
us
you know you need a car then you see an
advertisement on a car on a TV and you
say okay I won that car I'm gonna go and
buy that car and usually that car show
you more of the the facts of the car you
know the features the second one is the
peripheral route it doesn't really show
you the features of the brand but it
just play with your emotion with the
colors with the music with how
attractive is the model in it
ignoring the content facts and logic of
comedy like well is the anchorman
didn't say anything about the car 40%
increase in sales all right it's
interesting and this one this video this
video is really show us how subliminal
messaging in advertisement can really
impact us I invited two members of MBA
an advertising agency to a secret
location to propose an unusual task
those who work in advertising are
masters of persuasion they subtly weave
their images and slogans into our daily
lives knowing that we will register so
much unconsciously and then we walk into
a supermarket and feel a sense of
familiarity with the product we think
we've never heard of millions of pounds
a year is spent on it it's brilliantly
calculated and we all fall for it so I
thought I'd turn the tables on the
advertising experts thank you for
joining us gentleman Tony yes I'm Martin
yeah hi I'm Darren let me get down to
explaining exactly what I want you to do
imagine that I'm opening a chain of
stores selling a product something I
have a particular interest in your task
is to come up with a poster advertising
that store and that poster must include
the company name whatever you decide
that maybe it must include a strap line
some sort of slogan and some kind of
logo as well some kind of visual image
now the idea is you've only got half an
hour to do this he would have really
work with your first instinct so at the
moment you've got no idea what you're
going to do it correct yeah axles I'm
also going to give you this I've had a
few design ideas of my own I want to
leave this untouched we'll come back to
that later all right are there any
questions what's the product what's the
product very good question a passion of
mine since I was a toddler
it's a chain of taxidermy stores let me
pop the [__] count on the envelope
so it remains untouched you have half an
hour gentlemen creatures great and small
quality that says like nice positive and
the more heavy more animals go oh my
heaven it's gravy and lemon pepper but
the best animals go to lots of clouds
with animals on them yeah yeah where did
animals go to live where the best is the
best place for dead animals
it's simple time up gentlemen I can't
wait to see what you've done
come on show me okay and Tony before we
do this can you take the amber Pope you
earlier okay you please vouch for us
here that no one's been on you in there
it's been under a dead cat no one's
touched it that's not the truth as truth
people that come around here now before
we have another just tell me what was it
like we started off thinking about the
name I thought I was in we thought that
was probably the best thing to think
about in for sure and then take it from
there really we banged out a lot of ones
that would probably completely stupid
and then got down to the once I was
slightly stupid and then we kind of that
went back and forth for a bit and then
kind of got something we liked and
developed it can either look sure yeah
that's fantastic it's it's a bad with a
liar
so it's animal heaven the best place for
dead animals and it's obviously you
you'd see that it was stuffed how did
you come up with the name animal heaven
we had the idea of the pearly gates of
heaven been zoo gate zoo gates as the
gates of heaven that's interesting ie
sort of all the animals that dead are in
the dead zoo if you like in heaven and
then we just kind of thought well it's
kind of nice but it's a bit tweet we
want to make it a bit funkier and then
we thought hard plain bear Just Answer
answer debrief it's fantastic I do want
to show you my own ideas from beforehand
okay I don't want to touch would you
open them for me sure anyways I think
you'll find this interesting all right
not a million miles away let me put this
up there hang on to that it's yeah it's
a hard playing bear yeah God you've gone
for these angel wings here we think of
angel wings or Birdman yeah well they
were kind of a combination you do them a
lot better than me this was the same
thing I was thinking angel wings there
you've got animal heaven I got creature
heaven
yeah do you know where the best bit of
sailing a bit off there well the best
dead animals go could you put blessed
place without animals
I had the idea of a zoo it was hard to
leave we didn't want evil aims it was
hard to leave out wasn't was just a bit
too much
can I see your other room the other one
yeah it's just before they're very
different well let's just just to get
yeah Oh gentlemen please join quite
similar look at that this this was the
image I was thinking I've done it there
in the background because this to me was
the most striking image and interesting
me you abandon this for this well this
me yeah the first the first bear are two
looks exactly like that one well like
this is scary really look at that got
the cloud you've got the blue if you
knew the amount of effort we've gone
into making this work you'd be
absolutely flabbergasted but for now you
coming to know that you're just as
susceptible to subliminal persuasion as
the rest of us thank you very much
helping yourself Martin pleasure take
care thank you very much and doing quite
cynical and when I saw the bear and I
saw a cloud first of all become you know
behind the paper I thought hanging in
his clothes here and then when we saw
the rest of it I couldn't believe it I
immediately thought gutted I can see
that it was folded and I just saw the
Bears foot hanging over the cloud do the
harp yeah I just thought I can't believe
it yeah I'm guilty of embarrassing but
no nothing up fantastic and I'm over the
moon
I mean yeah well should we please for
him you know yeah he's yeah he comes
like this looking good the notes always
the main thing to see how we did it
watch their taxi journey again put a
spell on you
[Music]
cause you
you better stop the things you do
[Music]
so I mean that just shows you right
there your your influence by just
driving down the street I mean you see
things on the street in your peripheral
vision and that's impacting you so what
happens when you're sitting there
focusing on a TV and you're you're
actually giving it your attention it's
got to impact you that much they put a
lot of peripheral stuff in there and you
know the right the the directors they're
like put this thing in the background
and I want this here and the right thing
strategically placed right you know
aside from just what's on television
Duke University published a study that
said you're exposed to between I think
it's like 3 and 10,000 brands per day
well yeah because everything has a logo
and your brain is picking all that of
whether you're conscious of it or not so
what's the problem with all of this is
their problem though I think I I think
the problem really lies is let's just
say everybody had your best interest in
mind if they were putting ideas out
there like be a family man stay at home
take care of your kids have a good
relationship right think about what that
would do to society alright but instead
really the the things that they're
throwing mostly at us cars are too
expensive your phone is your expensive
clothes you don't really need you know I
mean it's like things that are not
necessarily helping you it's like
digging you into slavery financial
slavery really making you feel like you
missed out if you don't buy those but
it's not every yet there's some ads that
that are really trying to like change a
cultural you know thing like like racism
I don't think we should have racism in
our world you know I mean we're all
equal we're all in the same plane so
there are some companies that will
promote those kind of ideas that's great
use that platform to influence people
but if it's like hey drink coca-cola
which you can you know take the acid off
your battery with this stuff it's not
very good for you you know I think it
all stems from deep-rooted selfishness
you know there's no care for society per
se it's more money because you shouldn't
remember Steve Jobs I didn't see him as
much of a flashy guy right you know but
his company's associated with things
that are flashy or even clover Cola or
movie stars who don't let their own kids
watch TV so yeah it's selfishness yeah
yes I like this from this Psychology
Today it says the problem is that we
allow advertisers to have access to our
mental world they have paid for the
opportunity to slip information to us
about what feels good that information
ultimately affects the way we make
choices whether we know it or not so
that's really interesting like imagine
how many subliminal messaging we get
every day without even we're knowing so
we come to the conclusion so
advertisement does affect you oh yeah
whether you realize it or not whether
you want it or not they affect you yeah
people are in denial let's say it
doesn't for sure and because we know
that it affects us and things are going
into our minds subconsciously we should
make even more attempt to control as
much as we can and be mindful of what we
do choose to put in front of our faces
our minds Jim all right and why does it
affect us because advertisement trying
to make us feel good in this world that
is so busy and lonely sometimes we need
that yeah what do you call that
stimulation or know when gratification
validation validation yeah in this busy
world sometimes you need that validation
that you are worth it you are good and
we have this book here right here it's
called finding peace within this is a
really nice book it's a little
devotional if you want to feel peace
instead of looking forward to add
validation or media this book can be
good
is this a giveaway yeah how many we got
of these I don't you have to count so
supplies yeah how can you get it if you
go to so you can get the book by going
to our website little eye Studios TV
we'll put the link in the description
below to make it easy for you okay
and also the last thing is that the
Bible tells us to all to use our
reasoning and intellectual ability like
Isaiah 1:18 say that you know let us
reason together in profit there is a lot
of first as they say that we need to get
wisdom and understanding because it's
better than rubies and in Romans well be
not conformed to this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
also being separate from the world you
know what's a good verse that talks
about be separate but I know there is no
that's good alright so thank you guys
for tuning in and let us all keep our
mind on the Lord and see you next week
guys
[Music]